first of all congratulations on Criminal
Minds Evolution it got picked up for
season two I know this is just breaking
news really it's very very exciting uh I
can't believe we still get to do this
you know it's so wild when the series
ended in 2020 did you think a reboot
would happen this quickly
no I didn't
um I like we kind of had a feeling that
it would happen eventually but uh you
know not this fast uh I guess
people really got after it during the
pandemic and during quarantine we just
happened to have 15 seasons of shows for
people to sit and binge so uh that
definitely helped with the the
popularity of the show so yeah this
opportunity came up and
we've always sort of wished that we
could do the streaming version of the
show and it happened and we're we
couldn't be more thrilled so what do you
love about this season compared to the
previous seasons of Criminal Minds
uh this season feels a little a little
more I mean I'm gonna say it evolved
it's it's named well
um yeah it just feels like we are able
to make the type of show that we
couldn't quite make on network TV that
is not a slam to network I love Network
um it's just our our show is a a dark
show dark in nature we're studying
serial killers and how their minds work
um what I really love about this season
is for the first time we've been able to
just concentrate on finding this one bad
guy this this void character
um and that's been really cool to to
Really sink into a case and we're the
team keeps kind of coming up empty we
keep losing
um but that's all gonna start to change
soon we're gonna start to uh put the
pieces of the puzzle together and uh
there's some very exciting things coming
up on on the I think there's about three
more episodes left three or four
and that's when it gets good I mean the
whole season's been good but always like
towards the end you know you're ramping
out for like big moments uh let's talk
about exciting moments you're directing
an upcoming episode I am episode eight
it's uh called forget-me-nots uh this is
the second time I've been able to direct
on the show this was extra special for
me because it uh it is streaming so uh
you have a little more
um creative license I guess you could
say
um yeah and this time around
uh I had to direct my children which
part of me is like I am a crazy person
for signing up for this but uh I kind of
enjoyed it because they had to listen to
me they could not not listen to me yeah
otherwise I would included them out
offset
um but yeah this one was really cool
normally in the past they uh they always
tried to write our characters light if
we happen to be directing that episode
but with the streaming version there's
only 10 episodes so they can't really
give us too much uh too much time off so
for the first time on the show I found
myself having to direct myself uh in a
in a heavier kind of way there is a
pretty significant JJ storyline there's
a whole day of filming that we did at
JJ's house with uh with the family my
kids so it was a full day of working
with my kids not just acting but
directing and I just I had this Pinch Me
moment of
wow I can't believe this is happening
never in a million years did I think
that number one I'd be able to act with
my kids but to direct them as well was
just it just felt like such a special
unique opportunity and um we had a blast
we had a great time
how old are your kids ah gosh well
here's the other thing I think this is
what this is what will really blow okay
our viewers away especially the people
that have watched since the beginning I
mean obviously I've I've been pregnant
twice on the show I've had two kids on
the show for the world to see so I hope
we've been able to see these as kids
grow up well the kids are the the truest
marker of time uh so my oldest Makai who
plays Henry he's 14 now going on 16. the
kids like 5 10 already and uh and then
my youngest Phoenix uh he's seven so I
think it's going to be really cool for
the audience to see these kids how
they've evolved and I think it's it's
really cool that we've um we're we're
showing what it's like to be a kid of a
profiler for the first time we're gonna
kind of get to see it through their eyes
a little bit which I I think is is
really cool I mean what is that like JJ
has such a a full life she's married to
her job she's married to her family
she's married to her husband and she's
trying to be everywhere at once and yes
we see that struggle for her but you
know what's that struggle like for her
kids and we've seen it through Will's
eyes a little bit her husband but uh
it's it's a pretty cool special episode
coming up and we really really that we
hit the ground running with the with the
Elias Voight storyline we finally start
to make Headway in figuring out who this
guy is and let me tell you you do not
want to you don't want to miss the very
end of this episode because
it is good and then it just
pours us into episode nine and nine and
ten and holy smokes there's uh the fans
are gonna lose their minds
um they're I mean I can't give anything
away but wow you just know yeah how we
end the show how we end the season is
yeah amazing I can't wait
That's so exciting especially to feel
like a show that's been on for so many
seasons is feeling this Fresh So I think
that's so exciting for the fans and for
you too as an actress yeah absolutely uh
I've never strangely I've never been
bored playing JJ I feel like she's
always
evolving
um obviously I mean when we first saw
her she looked like she was a baby yeah
and she started out as a liaison so
we've been able to sort of track her
through her career moves and becoming a
profiler and becoming a mom and I've
been very lucky they've given me some
really great uh material to work with
and uh again this season we get to see
your family life a little bit more and
the struggles they're in and um they're
they've been faced with some health
issues as well so you know because JJ
doesn't have enough on her plate like of
course not let's give her something else
she can handle it right yeah
uh you know that first day on set of the
reboot what was it like reuniting with
the whole cast
oh my gosh amazing I mean we've been
we've just been waiting for this moment
uh and you know our Show wrapped after
15 seasons and then essentially the the
world shut down oh yeah Cove had
happened and the pandemic and uh so we
all couldn't even see each other even if
we wanted to because everything was
locked down
um so when we finally got this
opportunity we
couldn't couldn't have been happier
um let's just say there's a lot of hugs
um yeah yeah it's coming back home again
it feels it feels really nice
so you're on this hugely popular show
you also are celebrating a 20th
anniversary a final destination two did
you know it's been 20 years
holy smokes uh I do now
I mean I'm not gonna lie to you every
time I see a truck with giant logs on a
highway I always think of that movie
right I mean you can't not you how
quickly do you get around that truck
right oh I'm just like this not today
not today nope today is not my day did
you know that that would be such an
iconic movie like for my generation like
that is like ingrained in my brain yeah
you know I just I thought the first the
first one was so interesting and such a
cool concept so obviously when they came
to me for the the second one I was very
excited to get involved with it because
it's that is a story you can just keep
telling it's a it's a I'm not surprised
that it turned into the franchise that
it did because it's endless stories you
can you can tell that story you can be
as creative as you want
a person this time yeah yeah yeah it is
it's sort of this iconic franchise that
I can't believe I I got to be involved
in so it's pretty cool you've had this
amazing career but you and I share a bit
of a connection did you grow up in
Whitby
yes so did I
go did you go to Anderson so my whole
family went to Anderson I lived at
Richmond uh uh at fixin and Manning so
up the hill from Anderson but I actually
went to Sinclair I don't know if it was
like it just popped up when I went I was
a French immersion kid so I was like
Taunton Anderson but uh Anderson was
literally right down the street from my
house oh my gosh we were practically
neighbors this is hilarious I have
friends that went to Sinclair I went to
Anderson
um which is bizarre my dad went to
Anderson wow that's amazing it's been
there a minute uh
yes of course where else
Toronto was too far we just had to go to
Oshawa yep yep I love it I love that you
know the dirty schwa of course my roots
yeah uh well listen congrats on all your
success I can't wait for this uh season
to finish up but yeah I can grab some
season two thank you so much